and i remember thinking oh my god i
don't know what's going on here i lost
536 thousand kings against aces twice
now
and i have to get out of this town
you know before something
else happens bad i lost 536 thousand
and i called my wife and i said honey i
am not getting off the telephone
until we spend 460 000
for charities
take one helmet
yeah you know we lived in an upper
middle class neighborhood life in some
ways was idyllic but it was also hard
because
i was getting zero attention from my
parents and then
as time passed my brothers and sisters
and i competed for attention
with my parents and that was rewarded to
people that did well in school
i have add
adhd so i didn't do well in school and
so i think my father
with a phd
a jd and an mba i mean i don't know
anybody that has more letters than him
there was pressure to perform there was
pressure
to do well
growing up was you know
i was a disappointment to my father
to my father i was a loser because i
wasn't do it not a loser but i wasn't
doing well
in the areas they expected and you know
i remember then when he finally decided
to support poker and came to the main
event in 1989.
i was 24 and i said i'm gonna win it so
he flew out
and i won it and bought him a new
mercedes and
school was never brought up again
[Music]
well
the reading ability stuff you you learn
early if you're a poker player you know
and i mean i would do things that just
freaked other people out right i'd be
like i think you have exactly ten so i'd
isolate it down in my mind based on the
re-raised size
this person has jacks nines or tens
okay has to be jack's nines or tens has
to be based on my watching him play for
years and based on the way he's acting
so i'd be like all right you have pocket
tens
and they'd flip up tens and freak out
how did you know that exactly tens
are the cards marked well they didn't
they didn't actually think that because
they'd seen me use the trick so many
times
so i mean you know part of it is a guess
and so you know you just it's just
something that i became great at so it's
kind of a game i'd play you know and you
can't in every random hand you can't
guess what somebody has but in those
intense moments where the money starts
to be put in the story makes sense the
song makes sense the dance makes sense
this person dances this way
right and this music is playing has to
be pocket tense it's deductive reasoning
combined with
you know understanding the way a person
plays combined with the experience of
playing with that person combined with
other stuff that i can't even describe
as far as reading ability goes but no it
is an innate ability and i realized
early that
i couldn't teach everybody i'd have
friends i'm like oh i'm making all this
money playing poker let me teach you
i teach them perfect strategy but they
didn't have they couldn't dance and i
realized that you know
at that point in my life i kind of
started thinking wow how many people do
have this ability to read
and i started thinking it's ten percent
no no it's five percent no it's three
percent no it's two percent there's a
flow to poker there's a there's a a
dance
and
every song is different
and as you listen to the songs and the
dances of poker
you understand that this hand is worth
this much
at that moment against that opponent the
no limit hold them song and dance just
made sense to me
and i started playing on tour i realized
that there weren't four or five people
in the whole planet that had the same
understanding of the song and dance that
i did i mean we had johnny chan and
tj claudia and jack keller and i'm not
sure that they were that many other than
those three and i
you know back in the day we all have
strengths and weaknesses you know i
i'm about to play the main event and i'm
scared to death and on day three or day
four i'm just gonna give all my chips
away because i've done it a bunch of
times
so i'm giving this great gift
how to play perfectly right
but then you know what's my weakness
well i get a little too emotional i blow
it or
i get too tired and below it more often
it's the tired
so i've probably blown more tournaments
than anybody um just through exhaustion
was that realization that you're
spotting this rhythm that other people
aren't was that what made you so sure in
1989 that you were going to win the
world series like win the main event
going into the 1989 main event i'd won
we had like four big events per year
outside of the world series
and i'd won the
bicycle club main event which was and
finished second in the preliminary
so just boom boom and so i was on the
cover of all the magazines this was
august and i made some other deep runs
in some other tournaments and i just
thought wow i think
i think this is going to be my year so i
just started everybody telling everybody
i was going to win it it's set my
answering machine hey you're talking to
the 1989 world champion of poker um in
those days we had answering machines on
the night itself was there kind of was
there a sort of moment it clicked it was
like yeah i'm winning this tonight was
there anything sort of wider than the
table that just kind of leveled you and
made you think yeah tonight is the night
i felt very comfortable
you know i remember day three
feeling very comfortable
we went to day four
and the great johnny chan is still there
and
he had more chips than me and i just
kind of
sat back and you know
playing under cameras we're not used to
that we're playing under lights we're
not used to that
and now i had you know i had johnny 2-1
in chips after 35 minutes of play
he and i were basically you know really
both good at really really good heads up
we both played it a lot he stepped up
his aggression
and i said to him at like the 35 minute
mark i said
i'm playing perfect
you're either going to have to
you're gonna have to play perfect and
get lucky to beat me i looked at two
black nines and i said
all right here we go
i'm gonna make it 40. he's going to make
it 130. i'm going to move on it's like
the script was written i could see
pretty quickly i said a mullet
and you know i'm just kind of sitting
there and i'm like god don't snap call
don't snap call i think he studied three
minutes four minutes long time
and then finally
he called with the ace seven of spades
and now we're dealing for the whole
thing
and i i'm not sure i'm gonna win it i'd
watch them again and i'm like all right
you know and there was king kingtown
and i remember the queen of spades
coming on the turn and i'm just thinking
okay
no 10 no ace right give me a low card
you know nine would be great but
whatever if you look at the math
two and a half to one favorite before
the flop i'm two and a half one favorite
roughly with one card to come now and
i'm like okay
you've been in these moments never this
big but if he hits it
just make sure that you know that you
have 600 000 left
the blinds are 510
preparing
my mind because it's too big a moment to
tilt
i may have given a little poker brat
moment
and whined and complained but
i was not going to lose track of the
moment so i mean i was as shocked as
anybody when the six of spades comes up
i'm like oh my god i won this
and you know i mean my hands go up in
the air like this and there's a camera
above you know that one of those
circular it's a certain it's not even
from the set it's just a casino camera
security camera like there's shop domes
those ones yes exactly it's like a domed
right right and so the security camera
shows me going like this twice
and then i'm turning around looking for
my dad and my father comes running in
and uh security stops them because we
have you know
one a million dollars in cash on the day
this is 1989 you know and i'm like no
let them through it's my dad
and just to give him that hug you know
probably within 20 seconds of winning
and
i'd asked him to stay out of sight the
whole four days
when i was playing
so to give him a hug it was
an amazing moment we were doing a bit of
research i heard that there were you did
something quite peculiar in the build up
to 1989. like you decided to uh
you decided to
go on
some sort of band for a whole year
leading up to it oh you're talking about
the sex
yeah pretty well so yeah i mean i
decided i decided not to have sex listen
it wasn't was wasn't like i had it
wasn't like i had a lot of women after
me anyway women i was interested in you
know i just decided and then i remember
we were on a cruise ship
and i had some
opportunities to be with some really
beautiful women
and i'm like you know what if you do
this you're not going to win the main
event just a weird thing to just
randomly think
okay i won't do this
and so basically had no sex for
a year or maybe two years
going into the main events i was 24.
afterwards i said that's it i'm going to
open my life up you know i want it may
10 1989
and then you know
nothing happened i'm opening my life up
where are all the women you know nothing
happens
so i was playing phil ivey heads up
and like the hotel to cop i think in
monte carlo it's beautiful place our
suites were like two or three thousand a
night i luckily
neither one of us was actually paying
for us anyway so phil and i are playing
and
the next thing you know i'm done 100 000
which is one of the biggest losses of my
life and then i hit 200. i don't ever
remember losing more than 130 000
at that point in my life in a night ever
and it got to 300 400 536 000. but man
that one hurt uh
yeah and it wasn't just that it was like
i've never been back to monte carlo
since
and
i remember picking kings against
aces twice that trip
twice that trip once in the main event
and i remember thinking oh my god i
don't know what's going on here i lost
536 thousand kings against aces twice
now
and i have to get out of this town
you know before something
else happens bad
and i remember i i called a taxi
and my sister lived eight hours away in
bournemouth
and the taxi drove six seven eight hours
straight i was out of there before
midnight didn't even stay in my didn't
even finish the night in my suite i lost
536 thousand
and i called my wife and i said honey
i am not getting off the telephone
until we spend 460 000
for charities
or paying off the house
so i think we sent a hundred thousand
dollars
to doctors without borders we sent fifty
or a hundred thousand to another charity
she wrote a check to pay two hundred
thousand down on the house
right
because i said if i'm going to be
reckless and stupid and lose 536 000 one
night
then i feel like the charity should
benefit
and we should benefit
you know and so
and plus a million is a nice round
number
so i didn't get off the phone with her
and until i think it was only a 35
minute phone call but until she had
written the checks to the charities
written the checks to pay off the house
and
mailed them
and i finally got off my cell phone then
and then i went to bed
so
if you're going to do something stupid
like that then
you know
might as well
spend some money in the right way
[Music]
this is a braggadocio story ready for a
braggadocio story
we're at the kentucky derby
it's saturday night and one of my
friends says hey
why don't we take my plane
to watch the san antonio spurs playoff
game
you know
it was like cool
i'm like this is great but i have to get
up at nine in the morning or whatever
but fine this is great
so we hop on the jet the next day my
friend has seats like
in the second row or something
maybe first row he's one of the owners
of the spurs
and so then i kind of then
then at half time there's a place where
you can go if you're sitting on the
floor so i start walking up the tunnel
and tony parker
who just texted me actually
comes running down the tunnel this is a
playoff game
stops cold it's half time of a playoff
game stops colton says phil like tony
he's like i'm a massive fan
and talks to me for like 30 seconds and
then eva longoria who was married to at
the time who's even more famous
reached out to me and said hey can you
make it to tony's birthday party
and i said yes
and she gave me floor seats for the
dallas
san antonio playoff game in dallas
and those seats were worth like
30 000.
i'm just like this is just kind of a fun
life you know who would make you stop
say if you were playing final table main
event
what's celebrity with kind of well elon
musk
i mean alana alain alan is uh you know
alan and i have you know have hung out
and so you know i mean like we've had
we'd we'll drink tequila together and
just talk for a couple of hours
he does not play but he showed a little
interest recently from poker um he asked
me for a lesson you know donald trump
was
doing commentary when i was at a final
table he was in the booth which is weird
obama plays poker if tiger came
strolling in
you know tiger and i have
played high stakes blackjack together
all night and drank and smoked cigars
and so
but he probably would be like yo you
know
i think i'm just going to go into just
touch a little bit on the kind of your
blowups just going to talk to you quick
about that because well i found it
really interesting like me personally
looking at you because
blow-ups
is that what we're doing yes we are okay
perfect i found it really interesting
that people couldn't seem to comprehend
the idea of being really positive but
also having that kind of level that you
could go to have you had any kind of any
sort of issues like internally or
externally with trying to kind of show
show people that you can operate those
levels think of it this way you look at
you look at the past at some of the
biggest spiritual leaders and gurus in
the world and you say why is it these
spiritual leaders and gurus
have have a really hot temper
yeah it's like an oxymoron that hey phil
can be the poker brat
but phil is also the master of
positivity
cannot compute does not make sense right
and so i've seen some people object to
that you know and that's fine
um you know all i really want to do is
you know if i'm if i remember 100 years
from now i want to be remembered as the
greatest poker player of all time
not likely that people remember poker
players 100 years but maybe they'll
remember for the positivity movement
[Music]
the second goal goes in
and literally i'm planked on the floor
on my back
literally i think i actually nearly went
into tears
i was emotional screaming and to be fair
even now i feel quite emotional about it
i just thought oh my god
what have you lot just done
yeah i mean what have you like just in
my first words to all it you have no
idea what you've just done